modern businesses need to manage not
only the identities of their employees
but also the identities of customers
partners and things find out how to
manage customers in this episode of
who's there
[Music]
welcome to who's there a show where we
explore cloud identity today I am
talking about the app management facet
of cloud identity which is called
identity platform identity platform lets
you manage the identities of customers
partners and things through a single
service
it adds Google great Identity and Access
Management functionality to your apps
and services with identity platform you
can add a widely adopted user-friendly
and customizable authentication service
to your web and mobile apps with ease so
you can focus on building your app or
service it supports multiple
authentication methods including sam'l
oh I DC email password social Phone and
custom auth to provide flexible
integration options for any identity
solution you can access cloud identity
through a range of app SDKs for Android
iOS and web as well as server side admin
SDKs for node s Java Python and more to
get your app up and running even faster
identity platform provides a drop-in
customizable authentication service for
users sign up and sign in when Google
cloud built identity platform we wanted
to meet the demands of virtually any app
or service that's why it's built on
Google clouds global scale performance
network and security and it comes with
an enterprise-grade support in SLA you
can secure user accounts and scale with
confidence as it protects your apps
users and prevents account takeovers by
integrating with Google's intelligence
for account protection ok I think I've
spent enough time telling you why
identity platform is awesome let's dive
into how to configure it for your Google
project before you get started you need
to have a GCP project for which you are
a project owner with billing enabled for
that project once your project is ready
to go you can enable identity platform
from the GCP marketplace go to the
identity platform marketplace page in
the GCP console turn on identity
platform by clicking enable identity
platform next navigate to the GCP
console you are now ready to start using
identity platform client and admin SDKs
for your apps and services after you
enable identity platform you can
configure authentication methods so that
your users can sign into your
applications and services I'll choose to
enable email password for this example
now you know how to get identity
platform up and running so what comes
next
you can use identity platform client
SDKs for Android iOS and web to allow
end users to authenticate your service
you can also use its server-side with
the admin SDK to migrate users or
customize user access level and this
command-line option for migrating users
to identity platform to find out how to
complete the tasks and more check out
the documentation link below you can
also check out the getting started
videos for iOS Android and web and then
admin SDKs right here on the Google
cloud YouTube channel thanks for
watching who's there be sure to
subscribe to the channel to be the first
to know about new episodes of the series
[Music]
you